[Music]
hello my name is iJustine 2k and I am
friends with Scott - hey from hack
College pom today I am going to teach
you how to use an external monitor with
your MacBook Pro first things you have
to do is number one find the cord that
you want to connect to your MacBook Pro
once you have found the cord you will
notice that this is a VGA connector this
will not work with your MacBook Pro
because it has a DVI input find your
converter now that I have found my DVI
VGA converter I will simply will use my
skills as a puzzle master to fit the two
together it is very simple step 3 you
will now put the DVI converter into your
MacBook Pro
it is almost as if it is like magic that
your screen will now be here if you are
lucky enough to be on the Internet
plug in your internet now that I am here
on the internet I am able to browse a
website here and here this allows me to
save space and time on my desktop since
I just seen who's friends with Scott -
Kay from hack College calm since I just
seen signing off